Transcriber: Ahmet Görgendemir
Gözden geçirme: Ramazan Şen
Biz topluma bilimi anlatamıyoruz.
Anlatamıyoruz.
Ama bugünkü konuşmanın amacı neden
anlatamıyoruz, nasıl daha iyi anlatırız?
Biraz daha zorlarsak aslında anlarlar.
Herkese ders versek, akşam kursları yapsak
aslında çok daha bilimsel bir toplum olur.
Bunu demek değil,
bilimin çok yanlışları oldu
bilim anlatma konusunda,
bilimi topluma aktarabilme konusunda.
Genellikle de nerede hata yaptık
sorusunu sorduğumuzda
ilk baktığımız yer o iletişim kısmı
oluyor, bilim iletişimi kısmı oluyor.
Bugün size bilim iletişimini nasıl
yapmamız gerektiğini hiç anlatmayacağım.
Başlığı biraz motive etmek için koydum.
Asıl başlık biraz içimize dönersek,
"Biz nasıl yapıyoruz bu bilimi de
anlatamıyoruz kimseye?"
sorusuna yanıt bulmak.
Nasıl yapıyoruz
ve bunu nasıl yaptığımızı zannediyoruz ki
ona göre anlatmaya çalışıyoruz insanlara?
Biraz bunun üzerine sizinle beraber
bir istişare etmek istiyorum.
Topluma genelde anlatırken şunu söyleriz:
Bilim çok meşakkatli bir yol,
ince uzun bir patikada,
ne kadar uzağa gideceğimizi görmeden
ama bir yere varacağımız bilerek,
evrenin sırlarını keşfetmek için falan…
Böyle bir çalışa çalışa,
adım adım, ilmek ilmek,
işleye işleye falan…
Böyle anlatıyoruz değil mi?
Bilim nasıl yapılır dediğimiz zaman
kendimizi adıyoruz, çalışıyoruz,
ama bir patika var, bilinen bir patika var
onun üstünde gidiyoruz.
Gitmemiz gereken yönü biliyoruz,
nereye varacağımızdan emin olmasak bile
varılacak bir yer
olduğunu bilerek gidiyoruz.
Bu bayağı keşif üzerine kurulu.
Zaten aklımıza gelen bilimsel buluşlar
falan dediğimiz ama hep bir şeyi keşfetme,
işte atomu keşfetti falan gibi şeyler,
hep bir keşif üzerine gidiyor.
Bu bu analiz acaba doğru mu?
Hakikaten bilim
gerçekten keşifler üzerine,
bu patikada zorlana zorlana
ama yılmadan gittiğimiz bir yol mu?
Bunun üzerine biraz değinmek istiyorum
ve konu fizik olduğu için de
fizikten örneklerle, ağırlıklı olarak
fizikten örneklerle gitmek istiyorum.
Konu keşif olduğu için
eski zamanlardan bir harita,
dünya haritasından
örnek olarak vermek istedim.
Harita güzel bir şeydir.
Var olduğumuz dünyayı, evreni ne kadar
iyi bildiğimizi gösteren bir şeydir.
Bu, milattan 500 yıl önce
yapılmış bir harita.
Milet, Aydın tarafından,
bizim coğrafyamızdan kurulmuş bir harita
ve o zamanki evren bilgimiz bu kadar,
dünya bilgimiz bu kadar.
Ve görüyorsunuz ki işte Anadolu ortada,
etrafına biraz ulaşılmış.
Bilinmeyene gelince,
bugünkü bilgimizle biliyoruz ki
bilinmeyene gelince, ondan sonrası
deniz falan denilip bırakılmış.
Sonra iş değişiyor tabii.
1489′da böyle bir harita var, ilginç.
Asya’ya gelişmişiz,
Çin’e doğru gidilmiş.
Afrika biraz daha büyümüş, yanlış büyümüş,
tam anlamamışız onun şeklini şemâlini.
Ama bir şey eksik.
1489, yani Yeni Dünya’nın, Amerika’nın
keşfinden üç sene önceki bir harita bu.
Koskoca bir alan var orada bilmediğimiz
ve onu keşfetmeye gidiyoruz.
Farkındaysanız insanlık tarihi,
ne kadar büyük bir gezegende yaşadığımızı
zaman içinde öğrene öğrene gelişmiş.
En sonunda bugünkü dünya
deyince de bunu söylüyoruz.
Varmış olduk, yani bu keşif sürecinde
küçücük bir yerden, Anadolu’dan başlayıp
dünyaya varmış olduk ve bitti.
Artık dünyadayız.
Bilimi biz keşif olarak sunduğumuz zaman
toplum da böyle algılıyor olabilir.
Bir hedef var.
Dünyayı anlamak, evreni anlamak,
uzayı anlamak diye bir hedefimiz var.
Dolayısıyla ona vardığımız zaman da bu iş
zaten bitecek diye bir algı söz konusu.
O ince patikada tane tane, adım adım…
Bir bilime bakalım.
Bu bilimdeki bu keşif sürecine bakalım.
Çok güzel bir zaman çizelgesi var.
Bu gördüğünüz, en altta spiral şeklinde,
çok uzun bir zaman dilimi olduğu için
insanlığın başından beri gelen
süreçten bahsediyorum.
Yaklaşık 3 buçuk milyon yılı
açık açık yazmaya gerek yok.
Çünkü çok bir şey yapmamışız.
Alet edevat kısmıyla kalmışız orada.
Bronz çağı falan…
Onu spiral olarak koymuşlar, hepsini
bir araya toplayıp kenara bırakmışlar.
3 buçuk milyon yıl
insanlar bu dünyada var oluyor.
Ondan sonra yavaş yavaş başlıyor,
tarım falan, diğer konular giriyor.
Birkaç tane örnek buluşlara, gelişimimize,
bilim ve teknolojinin gelişimine
birkaç tane örnek vermek istiyorum.
Milatta önce 100 gibi kağıdı buluyoruz.
Sonra çok zaman geçiyor.
Cam’ı buluyoruz.
O ana kadar cam diye bir şey yok.
Sonra bayağı zaman geçiyor.
Mikroskobu buluyoruz, mikroskobun içinde
küçük canlılar olduğunu görebiliyoruz
mikroskopla beraber, çok ilginç bir şey.
Buhar makinesini buluyoruz.
Çok büyük bir…
Zaten endüstriyel devrimin
başlangıç dönemi.
Sonra 1800′den 1900′e geldiğimizde
atom çekirdeğini görüyoruz.
Orası çok hızlı geçiveriyor.
Bir anda cam buldum, kağıt buldum derken
yüzyıllarca geçen süreçlerde,
buhar makinesinden atomun çekirdeğini
görebilme, gözlemleyebilmeye gidiyoruz.
Ondan sonra uçak…
Yani ilk 12 saniye havada kalabilen
kağıttan bir yapı ile
ilk defa uçabilen insan,
66 yıl sonra Ay'a gidiyor.
Ne kadar hızlı,
ne kadar hızlı devindiğini anlatmak için
bir örnek olarak veriyorum.
İnce uzun bir patikada yavaş yavaş
bir yere doğru gitmiyoruz aslında.
Çok hızlanarak, ivmelenerek gidiyoruz
bilimi anlama konusunda,
bilimsel bilgi üretebilme konusunda,
evreni anlama konusunda.
Bu beyefendiyi eminim ki hiç kimse
elini kaldırıp ben tanıyorum demez.
Kendisi 1846 yılında,
iki doğum arasında,
iki çocuk doğumu arasında
ellerimizi yıkarsak çocuk ölümlerinin
azalacağını gösteren kişi.
Her beş çocuktan biri ölürken, her 100
çocuktan birinin öldüğü bir geçiş oluyor.
Sadece ellerimizi yıkadığımız için,
kullandığımız aleti temizlediğimiz için.
Hijyen.
1846, o kadar dengesiz gidiyor ki
bu büyüme, o patika diyorum.
1846, birkaç yıl sonra
atomun çekirdeğini bulacağız.
Yani o kadar dengesiz ilerliyor ki bilim…
Rastgele ilerliyor.
Biraz oradan… Bir patika daha var.
Orada başka biri…
Birisi patikada gitmiyor,
bambaşka bir ormanın
içinden geçmeye çalışıyor.
Bilim öyle tek bir çizgi halinde ilerleyen
ve aynı hızda ilerleyen bir şey değil.
Dallanıp budaklanan, bambaşka yerlere
gitmeye başlayan bir şey.
Bilim yapış şeklimiz de çok değişiyor.
Niye topluma anlatamıyoruz kısmında
bütün bu gelişimleri bizim kendimizin,
bilim insanı olarak
kendimizin ayak uyduramaması da var.
Bilimi anlat dediğiniz zaman söylenenlerle
nasıl bilim yapıyorsun dediğin zaman
söyleyenler arasında fark var bizim için.
Biz nasıl anlatalım topluma zaten,
tutarlı bir şekilde?
Bu ilk makale. Atom çekirdeği demiştim,
onu örnek veriyorum.
1911'de Ernest Rutherford'un
atom çekirdeğini gözlemlediği,
atomun içinde protonların rastgele
dağılmadığı, puding modelinin olmadığı,
merkezinde atom çekirdeği diye bir kavram
olduğunu gösterip tartıştığı makale.
Makaleyi yazan bir kişi,
Ernest Rutherford.
Bir masa üzerindeki deney cihazlarıyla
yapıyor, diğer insanlarla konuşarak.
Ama buluyor, bence artık bu diyor
ve bunun makalesini yazıyor.
Bir kişilik bir makale.
Ne kadar büyük bir olay.
Oradan beri, 1911'den beri…
Göstermek istediğim burada, bilimle ilgili
her şeyin ne kadar hızlı geliştiği.
Bilim insanı sayısı gelişiyor,
inanılmaz bir ritimde.
Bu grafiklerden bir tanesi,
doktora almış, bilim konusunda,
bilim ve teknoloji konusunda doktora almış
insan sayısı. Ne kadar hızla artıyor?
Bir tanesi bilime verilen fonlama.
Hep şikayet ediyoruz bilime fon az diye.
Doğru, bilime fon az ama inanılmaz
bir hızla da artıyor bir yandan.
Şu an az.
Keşke daha çok olsa ama olacak galiba.
Devam edersek biraz daha olacak.
Makale sayısı, inanılmaz bir artış var.
Daha çok bilim üretiyoruz,
daha geniş kapsamda bilim üretiyoruz.
Ama bir yandan da
daha zor bilim yapıyoruz.
Patika ile yola çıkmış olabiliriz belki.
Belki bir kişinin oturup atom çekirdeğini
bulabildiği bir dönem de olabilir,
onlardan kredi almadan.
Ama gittikçe daha çok bilgiye sahip olarak
yola devam etmemiz gerekiyor.
O yollar da patika olarak kalmadığı,
dallanıp budaklandığı için
çok daha fazla bilgiye sahip olarak
devam etmemiz gerekiyor
ve bunu tek kişi yapmak
neredeyse imkânsız.
En az atom çekirdeği kadar
önemli olduğunu düşündüğüm
bir başka makaleden örnek veriyorum.
Bu da kütleçekim dalgalarını ilk defa
gözlemleyebildiğimiz makale.
Onun sunulduğu makale.
Kontrast olsun diye
yazarlarını ekledim altına.
Bir kişinin bir laboratuarda
kendi başına yaptığı çalışma
ve o bilim iletişiminde
ne yazık ki biraz maruz kaldığımız
yalnız dahi, lone wolf,
kendi başına çalışan büyük düşünür
yapısından ne kadar uzağa
geldiğimizi gösteriyor bu.
Artık bir patika yerine
beş patikaya çevirmedi.
Otoyollar, uçaklar…
Bambaşka şekilde yapıyoruz biz bilimi.
Bir ekip halinde yapıyoruz.
Artık kişiler çok önemli değil.
Ekipler ve bir arada çalışabilme
çok önemli.
Dolayısıyla sorduğumuz sorular da çok daha
büyük sorular olabiliyor bir yandan.
Peki bu nereye gidecek?
Tamam patika değil, birkaç patika önünde.
Bir sürü yollar da var
ama gittiğimiz bir yer var.
Nereye gideceğiz?
Genelde öyle bir iletişim
yapıyoruz ki biz toplumla,
toplum bunu bulacağımızı zannediyor.
Her Şeyin Teorisi, "Theory of Everything".
Sonsuza giderken
bütün denklemlerin bir araya geldiği
ve her şeyi bize açıklayabildiği,
artık evrendeki her şeyi anladığımız
bir bilim anlayışı yaratmak istiyoruz.
İki tane bunu zorlayan
örnek vermek istiyorum.
Bir tanesi su, buz, buhar.
Çok basit bir şey.
Suyun kaç derecede donduğunu sorsam
hepiniz bilirsiniz bunu.
Suyun kaç derecede buharlaştığını,
gaza dönüştüğünü sorsam
hepiniz bilirsiniz.
Deneyimden dolayı da bilebilirsiniz
ama zannetmiyorum herhangi biriniz
mutfağınızda, "Bakayım su kaynadı mı?
99 derece oldu." demiyor.
Kaynadığı zaman az çok biliyoruz.
Dersten de biliyoruz,
yaptığımız araştırmalardan biliyoruz.
Bizim için gereken,
her şeyin teorisi dediğimiz zaman…
Bir suyu veya bir buzun içindeki
bütün atomları,
o atomların bir araya gelerek
oluşturduğu su moleküllerini,
o moleküllerin birbiriyle etkileşerek
oluşturduğu değişik fazların hepsini
açıklayabiliyoruz, anlıyoruz, biliyoruz.
Şu an benim elimde oradan başlayıp,
atomlardan başlayıp çözerek
suyun buharlaşma derecesini
bulabileceğim bir denklem yok.
Ben bir fizikçi olarak,
bakın mutfaktaki insan olarak demiyorum,
Bir fizikçi olarak, hesaplaya hesaplaya
suyun kaç derece olacağını bilemem.
Gözlemler ve empirik datadan yola çıkarak
Clausius-Clapeyron denklemlerini kurarım
kendi bilgim ve öngörüm ile.
Ondan sonra
doğanın yapısını anlamaya çalışırım.
Ama temelden hani en,
doğanın, evrenin en temel parçacıklarından
yola çıkarak bunları bulamıyorum.
Bu karmaşıklık bana çok geliyor,
bunu yapamıyoruz.
Böyle bir denklemimiz yok.
İkinci bir örnek, devre. Akım, devre.
Bir tane pil ve bir tane rezistörü
bağladığımız zaman
voltaj ve akımla orantılı…
İkisi arasında orantıyı kuran rezistördür.
Bu rezistörün çalışma prensibi,
yani bu devrenin çalışma prensibi
akımın artmasıdır.
Fizikçi olarak biliyorum
akımın nasıl artığını.
Elektronlar hareket ediyor
bakır telde, şöyle.
Elektronun ne olduğunu biliyorum,
kinetik enerjinin ne olduğunu biliyorum,
hızın ne olduğunu biliyorum,
bakırın ne olduğunu biliyorum.
Benim bunu çözebilmem lazım
ama o denklemi ben bulamıyorum.
Yine empirik bir denklem.
Elimizde fizik problemi yok.
Yani o denklemimiz yok.
Her bir elektronu sayalım,
hepsini toplayalım
ve karşısında bir Ohm's Law kanunu çıksın.
Böyle bir denklemimiz yok. Yine empirik.
Toplumla konuşurken
biz genelde şu şeyi yapıyoruz,
iki tane uçtan bahsediyoruz genelde.
Bunun iki sebebi var.
Bir tanesi bu konuda çok başarılılar
ve çok yatırım yaptılar
doğru yapmak için bunu. Çok iyi bir şey.
İkincisi de bunu yapmak kolay.
Bir tanesi, parçacık fiziği.
Bütün evrenin
temel yapı taşlarını bulmaya çalışıyor.
Ondan daha temel bir şey yok.
Bunu biliyorsam
geri kalan her şeyi bilirim demektir.
Diğeri bütün evrenin ne olduğunu
anlamaya çalışıyor.
Ne kadar büyük olduğunu
İki uç, birbirinden farklı iki uç.
Ve toplumu motive eden de bu aslında.
Bu işe yarayacak mı deniyor bize genelde,
yeni bir araştırma sonucu falan.
Ama aslında toplumu motive eden,
aslında toplumun bilime hala tutunması
Bu kadar temel soruları
sorabiliyor olmamız.
Aslında o, ona tutunalım.
Ama ortada inanılmaz büyük bir alan var
ve toplum bundan çok haberdar değil.
En azından bunun yekpare, kendi başına
devinen bir şey olduğundan haberdar değil.
Yoğun madde fiziği diye bir dal var,
bu öyle bir dal ve öyle bir dinamik ki,
patika örneğinden yola çıkarak,
o ormanın içinde kendi kafasına göre
hareket eden insanların topluluğu bu.
Belli bir amaç uğruna,
CERN gibi veya diğer şeyler gibi,
Webb Teleskobu gibi çok büyük projelerle
yola çıkmak değil de,
daha küçük ama çok dağınık
bir şekilde çalışan bir
donanma değil de korsanlar birliği,
kendi kendilerine çalışan
korsanlar birliği gibi düşünebilirsiniz.
Ve buna kimya, biyoloji falan da
dahil oluyor ara ara.
Biyofizik diye bir kavram var,
fiziksel kimya diye bir şey var falan…
Orada karman çorman oluyor.
Disiplinler arası çalışma
dediğimiz yer işte orası, tavı orası.
Bir örnek vereceğim size.
Niye yoğun madde fiziğinin
bu kadar iyi çalıştığı ile ilgili.
Gördünüz, bir tane şey var, dalga var.
Burada da güzel… Fizikçi olduğum için
tabii ki demonstrasyon olacak.
Bu ip, değil mi?
Dalgayı görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Gidiyor ve geliyor.
Aslında giden gelen hiçbir şey yok.
İp durduğu yerde duruyor.
İpin yaptığı tek şey
yukarı aşağı gidip gelmek.
İpin her bir parçası ilmek ilmek
sadece yukarı ve aşağı gidip geliyor.
Bu tarafa akan ve oradan geri seken
hiçbir şey yok, hiçbir madde yok.
Bunu, bu gördüğünüz dinamiği ben,
her bir ilmeğin tane tane yukarı ve aşağı
inmesiyle de açıklayabilirim.
Ya da dalga diye
yeni bir parçacık yaratırım
ve onun özelliklerine bakabilirim.
Bu işte tam bizim yaptığımız şey,
parçacık fiziğinin çıkış konusu.
Benim temel parçacıkları
bulmama gerek yok.
Ben parçacık yaratırım
ve onun dinamiğini kurup
yeni bir teoriye doğru,
yeni bir modellemeye doğru gidebilirim.
Nasıl yapıyoruz bunu?
Foton ve elektron, parçacık fiziğinin bize
verebildiği iki tane çok güzel madde var.
Parçacık, foton, ışık, elektron,
maddenin yapı taşı.
Biz tabii hemen yoğun madde fizikçisi
olarak diyoruz ki, "Bir dakika!".
Elektron doğada bulunan pozitron
olmadığına göre, antimadde,
rahatça laboratuvarımızda bulabileceğimiz.
Bunun tersini yapalım. Her taraf
elektron olsun, bir elektron eksik olsun.
Bunun adı deşik.
Yeni bir parçacık yarattık.
80 milyar elektron nerede
diye sormak yerine,
eksik olan elektron nerede sorusunu sormak
bir anda çok basitleştiriyor işi.
Ben istediğim bütün fiziği
bununla yapabiliyorum.
Elektron ve deşik beraber.
Elektron ve deşik beraber olduğunda,
o zaman buna eksiton diye
yeni bir parçacık adı veriyoruz.
Artık iki parçacıktan oluşmuş
iki fermiyonun birleşip bozon olmasıyla
yepyeni bir parçacık çıkıyor
ve bu ışık ile iletişim kuruyor
ve biz polariton diye
yeni bir parçacık üretiyoruz.
Elektron, deşik, elektron eksikliği,
atom gibi, bir de ışık koyuyoruz üzerine,
hepsi beraber polariton oluyor.
O içinde bulunduğumuz kristal
dalgalandığı için belli bir ısıda,
o dalgalanmalar da
işin içine katılabiliyor.
Bazen o eksiton ve fononu birleştirip,
polaron diye bir parçacık yaratabiliyoruz.
Oradan çok güzel anlayabiliyoruz
maddenin ve doğanın nasıl işlediğini.
Ve bunun gibi bir sürü daha parçacık var.
Sonu yok bunun.
O kadar çok parçacıklarımız var ki.
Biz parçacık bulmuyoruz, yaratıyoruz.
Bu bize şunu sağlıyor,
parçacık kavramıyla başladığımız yolda
önce biz o parçacıklarla
yeni bir fizik buluyoruz.
O fiziğin kendi yarattığı parçacıkların
ne olduğunu tespit ediyoruz.
O yeni parçacıklarla yeni bir fizik
ve fenomenler yakalıyoruz.
Ondan sonra yeni parçacık
ve bu döngüsel şekilde devam ediyor
ve gittikçe daha kompleks hale geliyor.
Ve bir parçacığı biliyorsam,
35 milyon parçacığı bir araya koyup onun
ne yapacağını tahmin edebilirim demiyoruz.
Çünkü bunu yapmak imkânsız.
Her aşamada maddeyi yeniden tanımlıyoruz.
O parçacığın ne olduğunu
yeniden tanımlıyoruz.
Buraya çok küçük bir gönderme yapacağım.
1947'nin "less is more" konsepti,
minimalizmin başladığı,
çok aktif olduğu dönem.
Benim de çok sevdiğim,
mimari olarak çok sevdiğim bir konu.
Fizikçiler bunu alırken tabii
yıllarca yıllarca biraz yanlış yaptık.
Biz bunu… "Assume a spherical cow",
yani ineği modelleyeceksek
küre olarak aldık o ineği biz.
Dolayısıyla bu basite indirgeme,
indirgemeci yaklaşım yüzünden
aslında pek çok fenomene
ulaşma şansımızı yitirmiş oluruz.
Ama bu anlattığım şekil,
kompleksiteyi, karmaşıklığı artıra artıra
her kademede yeni bir fizik yaratma,
yeni fizik terimleri, terminolojisi
tam buna zıt olan kavram
ve en başarılı kavramdır şu an bu fizikte.
Bunun da çıkış noktası Anderson,
harika bir insan.
"More Is Different" diyerek
kat, daha fazla şey kat
ama amaç daha çok olması değil,
sayı anlamında çok değil,
Yeni kavramlar,
yeni modeller anlamında çok.
Ve şu anki yoğun madde fiziği,
yani fiziğin aslında en büyük dalı,
tamamen bunun üzerine yürütürken…
Bunu iki amaçla koyuyorum, renk paletini.
Bir tanesi, paletteki renkleri bulmak
ve bütün paleti tamamlamak gibi gözüken
ve artık her şeyi anladık,
elimizde bütün bilgiler var,
doğayı anlamak için gereken
her şey elimizde mevcut
kavramından çıkmamız gerekiyor
ve çıkıyoruz. Bilim çıktı.
Bunu topluma anlatırken de
bu kısmını es geçmemeniz gerekiyor.
Bilim sadece bir bilgiler topluluğu değil,
bir liste değil,
aynı zamanda bir yaratıcılık rolü.
Yani bu renkleri kullanarak
aslında yapmak istediğiniz şey
yeni fikirler, yeni yaklaşımlar yaratmak.
Belki de yeni madde,
yeni fiziksel kurallar inşa etmek.
Ama ikinci bir örnek de
bilimin kendisinin ne hale geldiği,
bu kadar hızlı devinen bilimin nasıl
şekillendiği ve değiştiği ile ilgili.
O da, palet. Eski usul fizik,
kimya, biyoloji, birbirinden bağımsız,
birbiri ile konuşmayan disiplinler
ve araştırma dalları değil,
tam tersine iç içe geçen
ve sürekli birbirinden bilgi alan,
birbirine bilgi veren ve beraber
ortak çalışabilen yeni bir yapı.
Gördüğünüz gibi Kandinsky'nin tablosu,
benim için asıl örnek.
Yaratıcılık aslında orada.
Teşekkür ediyorum.